con gran difusión las operaciones en la
presa de mayor altitud de china han
comenzado a 3000 metros sobre el nivel
del mar según medios estatales la presa
de lianghekou está situada en la
confluencia de tres ríos el ya long el
chen shui y el quinta en el suroeste de
la provincia de sichuan es la nueva mega
presa de china y las autoridades esperan
que ayuda a cumplir los ambiciosos
objetivos climáticos y de energías
renovables del país que pretende
alcanzar la neutralidad climática en
2060 estas son las válvulas que
regularán el flujo del agua de la presa
al parecer será la presa de mayor
altitud del mundo estoy orgulloso de
estar aquí
estamos orgullosos de trabajar en una
empresa como esta para nuestro país la
energía hidroeléctrica puede ayudar a
reducir el consumo de carbón pero la
presa de lianghekou ha tenido un impacto
humano enorme desde que comenzó la
construcción del colosal proyecto en
2014 algunas comunidades locales muchas
de ellas de etnia tibetana han sido
desplazadas o forzadas a reubicarse de
las 100 familias del pueblo 70 serán
reubicados en el río y along el
monasterio budista también se verá
afectado
tenemos que mudar
no tenemos otra opción si no sería
peligroso y
las casas serán destruidas y ni siquiera
estamos seguros de que nos compensa
los desplazamientos suelen ir de la mano
de la construcción de las mega presas
chinas la presa de las tres gargantas en
la provincia de hebei la mayor del país
y del mundo desalojo a más de un millón
de personas a lo largo del río yangtzé y
también ha tenido un coste
medioambiental provocando
desprendimientos de tierra y dañando la
biodiversidad las aproximadamente 24.000
presas y han permitido al país
convertirse en el mayor productor
mundial de energía hidroeléctrica estas
generan alrededor del 18 por ciento de
la electricidad del país pero a pesar de
las importantes inversiones en energías
renovables el país sigue siendo el mayor
emisor de carbono del mundo con el
carbón como su principal fuente de
energía